so I have a rectangular prism here we're
given two of the dimensions the width is
two the depth is three and this height
here we're just representing with an H
and what we're going to do in this video
is think about how does the volume of
this rectangular prism change as we
change the height so let's make a little
table here so let me make my table so
this is going to be our height and this
is going to be our volume V for volume
and so let's say that the height is five
what is the volume going to be pause
this video and see if you can figure it
out well the volume is just going to be
the base times height times depth or you
could say it's going to be the area of
the square so it's the width times the
depth which is six times the height so
that would be 2 times 3 times 5 so 2
times 3 times 5 which is equal to 6
times 5 which is equal to 30 30 cubic
units we're assuming that these are
given in some units so this would be the
units cubed all right now let's think
about it if we were to double the height
what is going to happen to our volume so
if we double the height our height is 10
what is the volume pause this video and
see if you can figure it out well in
this situation we're still going to have
2 times 3 2 times 3 times our new height
times 10 so now it's going to be 6 times
10 which is equal to 60 notice when we
doubled the height if we just double one
dimension we are going to double the
volume let's see if that holds up let's
double it again so what happens when our
height is 20 units well here our volume
is still going to be 2 times 3 times 22
times 3 times 20 which is equal to 6
times 20 which is equal to 120 so once
again if you double one of the
dimensions in this case the height it
doubles it double
the volume and you could think of it the
other way if you were to have if you
were to go from 20 to 10 so if you have
one of the dimensions it has the volume
you go from 120 to 60 now let's think
about something interesting let's think
about what happens if we double two of
the dimensions so let's say so we know
I'll just draw these really fast we know
that if we have a situation where we
have two by three and this height is
five we know the volume here is thirty
thirty cubic units
but now let's double two of the
dimensions let's make this into a ten
and let's make this into a four so it's
going to look like this and then this is
going to be a four this is still going
to be a three and our height is going to
be a ten so it's going to look something
like this so our height is going to be a
ten I haven't drawn it perfectly to
scale but hopefully you get the idea
so this is our height at ten what is the
volume I'm going to be now pause this
video and see if you can figure it out
well four times three is 12 times 10 is
120 so notice when we doubled two of the
dimensions we actually quadrupled
we actually quadrupled our total volume
think about possibly to think about why
did that happen well if you double one
dimension you double the volume but here
we're doubling one dimension and then
another dimension so you're multiplying
by two twice so think about what would
happen if we doubled all of the
dimensions how much would that increase
the volume pause the video and see if
you can do that on your own in general
if you double all the dimensions what
does it do to the volume or if you have
all of the dimensions what does that do
to the volume